you got an awesome new app and now you
need to think about securing it and your
users data whether you made an app about
time travel kittens or hover bikes
you're probably asking the same question
it's my absolution is unique securing
applications is just as unique in this
video you'll see the example app we
created and how Google cloud helped us
secure it security isn't a
one-size-fits-all solution for example
Romanian banking app you're gonna have
different concerns than someone making a
photo sharing app but we can't show you
how to secure a net we haven't seen so
instead we created add a cat to that to
show you how Google cloud helps you
secure your apps how do you use this
fantastic application start with an
awesome photo like the one gent on took
in San Francisco you send it up to the
cloud we do sophisticated artificial
intelligence to add cats now we send
that photo back to you improved and it
even works recursively because everyone
knows the internet benefits from more
cats and voila your photo is better so
how did we make it all happen behind the
scenes it's actually a very short Python
program about 20 lines of code
implemented using the flask framework
once we get the photo we kick it over to
image magic that adds to catch the photo
and we take the result and send it back
to our cat lovers better than it was
before next we had to think about how
are we going to run the software we
deploy this inside a container a
lightweight and portable executable
image that contains software in all its
dependencies this lets us speed up
development and deployment to production
since we're using a container we're able
to use cloud run to click a button and
that creates the image runs the image in
production and prints our domain at it
so the app can surf cat images to real
humans now we're up and running and the
question that always gets asked is add a
cat to that secure hmm that's a little
more complicated even with an app as
simple as add a cat to that we've got a
lot of work to do to keep our
application from becoming one of those
security horror stories you read about
in headlines so what do you think can
you see any potential vulnerabilities
let us know in the comments below and in
the next video we'll show you what we
fixed I'm Carter this is max thanks for
watching and for adding more cats to
your photos
[Music]